you've obviously had this great career
and a lot of accomplishments but you
seem to also be
particularly adept at being the buddy in
a buddy movie you just i mean
so many times you've been that guy and
it almost feels like you're a
hollywood's go-to
we need a you know we need someone to
play opposite
it's almost like you're a great musician
that way we need someone to play
opposite
will ferrell you know and who is that
guy and you seem to be
perfect we have this repellent star
and we have to find someone who's able
to get along with him enough to
to portray his best friend
uh know that you're the truth there's
only one yeah it's only one best run
part i had to play where i
where i didn't quite feel like the
person's best friend by the end of the
project but
for the most part i i do uh this guy
wants to know who i know
i i i love that our cameraman went
huh like no we were not
it would be rude to ask but who was it
uh i don't want to say
but what i was going to say is that good
try
is that i you do end up becoming best
friends with people in a way like
um even in a movie that wasn't
necessarily a comedy or whatever
like obviously will and i are very very
close friends
but joaquin phoenix and i just did this
movie the sisters brothers
and you know joaquin is like a wild
animal you know it's like watching a
raccoon go through the garbage on screen
you're like what is it going to do now
like
right so i didn't know what it was going
to be like with him and it did take us a
second it took him a second to trust me
that i was just
there to like you know do do the best i
could and
i wasn't going to judge him or whatever
and now i swear to god i would do
anything for that guy i would take a
bullet for walking in phoenix yeah
because you just end up through the
fictional
friendships you end up getting so close
to people
um yeah it's a beautiful thing and i i
think part of it
is that i have the ability
and i've recognized this in myself i
have the ability to be either the alpha
or the beta and i can flip back and
forth and will pharaoh is like that too
you know
not everyone is often the star of movies
you know like they're just
the star like alpha guy and that's that
but i'm always able to you know deliver
when you need me to be
uh you know the alpha but i can also you
know
stand back and like let the other person
have the floor and i think that's
that's an admirable quality in anybody
do you do you think
i mean people must be asking you all the
time about a stepbrother sequel if
there's going to be another one
only when i leave the house
[Laughter]
only when i leave the house am i asked
that question i've called you
at home and asked you so that's not 100
true
that's true phone interviews often get
around to that yeah
yeah it's a beloved movie i mean i i
love it
yeah so much of that movie has stories
from my own childhood in it
you know will and adam and i all sat
around together basically just trying to
make each other laugh
for weeks and weeks and a lot of you
know don't touch my drum set
you know getting getting beat up by a
gang fight worth of kids and
a lot of that stuff just came right out
of my life so
it felt very personal and i know it felt
very handmade in a way too yeah
the fact that will and adam made it and
then you know the surprising thing was
like
like the appeal among not just younger
people or
like the whole family was you know the
all the moms were like
oh i just wanted to grow you up that's
that's what will's mom said to me at the
premiere party she's like
oh me and my friends just love this
movie we just want to grow you
up well good luck with that you know
like
the movie ends we're kind of exactly
where we were
no progress is made but i don't know
like i think
i think like like a lot of artists
all three of us are kind of felt like
well you know unless we could unless we
were really
sure that we could do a better version
or improve on what it is
right let's leave it alone and sequel is
cool sequels are hard to pull off
yeah they are i i mean aliens maybe but
god father two god for other two is also
but the fact that you can list
maybe there's maybe two or three
examples where the sequel was as good or
better and then there's a list of
failures like as long
long as the day